what is going on there reject nation we
got ourselves a special look trailer or
something that people were sending me
saying that this trailer is awesome it's
only like a minute long but i'm sure
it's gonna generate some thoughts if you
all can leave a like please do that
that'd be very much appreciated doesn't
take too much work on your end we are
going to be going to the thor love and
thunder premiere so excited to see what
it's all about make sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our instant reaction and
honest thoughts review is up here on the
channel all right guys
let's see what's going on
[Music]
he's gonna do a speech
wow
you're afraid
i'm scared
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry me it's very hard to get a
rousing speech with the
noise oh god we're going to die
new asgard draxer this is my vow
oh god she will die
that seems a bit dangerous
this
sounds like uh a combination between
heath ledger and um
scotty from the first star trek movie
yeah definitely it was exciting because
i didn't expect to hear gore do a voice
like that i can't wait to see the
versatility of christian bale's gore
here because i feel like the trailers
are mainly showing us like those real
menacing moments those creepy horror
moments with the character but this is
taiko waititi and as much as people
might not want to hear it imagine
there's going to be some individuals out
there who go i don't want them to ruin
gore and make it like a goofy thing i
don't think they'll make gore
necessarily goofy however i think there
will be some type of layer or element of
humor but on the flip side i'm so used
to seeing christian bale being an
incredibly serious actor and i hear like
from what the other actors have said
about working with christian male in
this movie that he still did show up
pretty much in character embodying the
role i don't really associate christian
bale with doing like comedic stuff ever
he can be funny in some roles but even
in those funny roles he's still a pretty
serious actor so i i like the idea of
seeing him kind of finding the humor
within the villainy of this character
you know yeah yeah totally i mean i feel
like as long as they don't take him and
turn him into a joke some element of
contrast-based humor i think is
appropriate and i think yeah it would be
a lot of fun to see christian bale
embody because he's already like from
these glimpses we got looks so
menacing terrifying you know just these
images we see of him rending work like
we know the threat level and so here
while you know everybody gets a little
wary and up in arms about marvel humor i
feel like you know that was actually a
nice little uh you know seasoning for me
in this trailer and then you know among
a bunch of really badass images i mean
they really honed in on so much of the
really cool and really striking action
that's gonna take place in this movie
and it looks like a very sprawling and
expansive movie at that and so while you
do have gore to look forward to you also
have like so many other things it feels
like yeah i mean unlike the thor
ragnarok movie which still felt a little
bit more
of the
fantasy realm with kind of a
sci-fi tone to it this really feels like
a space adventure yeah it seems like
you're going across different planets
and and dimensions and just going all
over the place so it feels very apt to
continue that whole um you know as
guardians of the galaxy thing at the
very top of this film but i do have this
pause right here i wanted to read this
the whiteboard asgard korg get the
popcorn out he's going to do a speech
and see what's happening here direct
quote you're afraid uh my friends it's
times like this we need to unite unite
oh yeah okay yeah meeks blocking it okay
i see what's going on there lightning
bolts and stars and mjolnir i think that
this film actually has a little bit more
the scale of this the scope of
everything that it's it's gonna be
exploring feels just so much more grand
i'm really loving a lot of the moments
that we are getting with the guardians
of the galaxy they're so sparse in these
trailers but i feel like they will be
ultimately substantial maybe they won't
be in it throughout probably just like
the first act of this movie or maybe the
first half of this movie but i can't
tell if they're going to be in it for 10
minutes or 30 minutes
like it's somewhere in between there but
i like the idea of them being a part of
you know thor's transformation process
early on in this film transformation
there you go the transformation process
in this film because you know this is
taking place you know uh right after end
game and we're gonna see him physically
change so i wonder if there will be some
type of commentary about physical change
in the form of being confronted with the
identity of jane's mighty thor oh yeah i
mean too because you also have him
shedding his game earth or weight and
things like that so there's a lot of
physicality baked into the roll as well
as then the contrast of change in jane
and everything and there's so much to
play with and i love that you have these
bits and pieces that are like weird
little character quirks or character
physical attributes that are also sort
of being honed in on and used for more
than jokes or more than just a quick gag
or a quick sight you know based uh
reference or something like that you
know i just can't wait to see uh chris
hemsworth's ass in action i know man we
gotta get some cheap dancing we gotta
get a little twerk on first pg-13 marvel
movie for partial nudity no
progression we're progressing big time
first eternals man with that very very
uh low-key love scene and now this thor
butt well i mean we can go there but any
little hint of gay stuff well there's
too many parents who have to have to
give their kids a giant lecture about
what the hell is going on in this
goddamn universe all right guys well
what did you think about this footage
yeah i know i haven't been covering like
a whole bunch of the footage but hey
guess we're slowly dialing that back or
we're just so busy covering other shows
and stuff guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell last but
not least
the mighty everett pixel might
baker everett pixelmybaker i like to
think you know we got so many buff godly
characters in this in this movie coming
up and you've got you know might in your
name and i always think to myself at
first like oh yeah pixel might you know
mighty strong but i like to think now
that maybe your name is ironic you know
like maybe you are a really scrawny guy
maybe you don't lift much maybe you
don't get out that often but the
strength of the might of the everett is
in your character my dude so no matter
what you look i don't even know what you
look like no matter what it is
you are mighty of spirit my guy you are
mighty of character and that's all that
matters you have been here for so long
that shows dedication that shows loyalty
that shows uh you know questionable
taste and all of those things come
together to form the unique being the
god-like presence that is you my friends
so stay healthy stay humble and hey
maybe go out and uh you know do some
lifting man get some sick gains you know
get jacked get yoked man get ripped
get uh
boosted get get you know thick with four
c's you know what i mean
love you buddy we'll catch you next time
[Music]